♪ ♪ ♪
- Tous les agriculteurs
vous le diront : chaque saviviv.
- Le printemps a mal déb
Dans notre coin, on a eu
de la grosse pluie, de
que normalement, en tout cas,
on a rarement vuesààà.
- Marcel Michaud cultive la
pomme de terre
- La maturité, on l'a défoliée
à peu prè j j jours passé.
- Il y a les aléas de la météo
et la haus
carburant, mais un autre élément
s'ajouu u u casse-tête :
le prix des engrais.
MARC
propriétaire, Fermes GAM
Ça a comme pas d'allure!
Tu sais, je veux dire, qu'est-ce
Ça a comme pas de bon sens.- - s
les chaînes d'approvisionnement,
causé par la guerre en Ukraine
et sanctions du Canada contre
la Russie : la facture d'engrais
cette année.
- Quand tu as des "curveball"
comme ça, excusez l'expression,
- Ottawa a imposé des tarifs
de 35 % sur  l l les produits
en provenance de Russie,
y compris le
Avant l'imposition des tarifs,
85 à 9dededes engrais utilisés
dans l'est du Canada
prov
Le choc est brutal.
- rtrtrtitude, inquiétude,
je vous dirais; ça décrit
que vivent les agriculteurs.- -s
agricoles réclame la levée
CHARLES-FÉLIX ROSS, directeur
général de l'UPA
- Moi, je pense que
fausse route. Une décision
qui va à taxer les engrais,
c'est taxer la nourriture.
du G7 à imposer des tarifs
sur les engrais en provenance
de la Russie.
de l'ONU décourage les barrières
tarifaires sur les engrais
russes pour éviter d'empirer la.
Pourtant, le gouvernement
Trudeau maintient la ligne dure.
CHRYSTIA FREELAND, vice-premièrs
- Tous les Canadiens sont pour
un régime de fortes sanctions
contre la Russie. t t t t t t ts
ministres autour de la table
du cabinet ne sont pas d'accord
avec les tarifs sur les engraise
des Finances reste ferme.
Le premier ministre n'exclut pas
d'aider les agriculteurs. T T T,
premier ministre du Canada
- Les coûts pour
nos agriculteurs à travelelelel.
- En préparation pour
la prochaine saison, l'industrie
doit trouver des solut r r r r .
La plus importante coopérative
agricole au Canada peut se
tourner vers l'Ouest canadien ce
la potasse, mais ce n'est pas
suffisant pour combler
tous les besoins.
direction de Sollio Agriculture
- Qu'on continue de mettre
l'accent sur l'approvisionnement
l'Égypte, l'Algérie...
- Ilttttttend à une nouvelle
augmentation des prix de
25 à 50 % l'année prochaine
Le Canada s'en prend
à la mauvaise cible, selon lui.
- Est-ce que ça a un impact sur
les producteurs russes? Pas du
tout. Seulement les producteurs
du Canada.
- Marcel Michaud n'est pas
contre les sanctions, mais
se sent désavantagé face
aux cultivateurs américains,
- Le problème là, je veux dire,
moi, ça me dérange pas de paye
le même prix, de payer cher mon
engrais, mais si ma compétition
pa
- Il tente lui aussi
de s'adapter, de trouver
des variétés de pommes de terre
qui nécessitent moins d'engrais.
qui sont plus hâtives pour...
qui performent bien.
- Mais le processus d'essais
et erreurs est coûteux et peut
crise, le poids sur les épaules
des agriculteurs dntntnt lourd
à porter.
- Il y a des jeunes qui vont
la relève. Non, j'ai pas besoin
de ça, t'saiC'C'C'est dommage.
- Pour Marcel Michaud,
l'horizon s'est assombri.
ses efforts et la qualité
de sa te l l le fruit de
son travail lui écha Blo Blo Bl,
Saint-André, Nouveau-Brunswic